ann heisha's story continues with
unexpected family drama and a surprise
new memoir set for release early next
year i've written one and i've written
another one the actress teased this book
for years now we know it's called call
me anne and according to the publisher
the 140-page autobiography will revisit
anne's rise to fame it's being described
as part self-acceptance workbook
including poems prompts and exercises
that got in through tough times it's
difficult to anticipate what people are
going to think the memoir stands as a
follow-up to her first call me crazy
which she released in 2001 after a
headline making mental health episode i
wrote the book for me i wrote the book
to give closure to my life and also
because i'm a creative person i could
have written a novel i didn't
i wrote about my life so there you go
anne died last month at the age of 53
she was declared brain dead following a
fiery car crash and now her family is at
odds over control over her estate it's
intense in a legal filing obtained by et
james tupper and ex and father of her 13
year old son atlas is objecting to
anne's other son 20 year old homer
lefone's request to be placed in charge
homer no he's a businessman he's going
to run my business for me someday james
claims anne sent him an email in 2011
which allegedly told him that if she
died he would be in control of all of
her assets and that they will be divided
equally among her children when they
turn 25. while the former couple was not
romantically involved at the time of
anne's death james says he still has the
right to hold decision making over her
estate because they share a minor i'm a
dad that's what dads do he argues
there's no urgent need to change the
administrator and says homer is not
suitable because of his age and his
current unemployment status a hearing is
scheduled for october 11th
[Music]
you